dota was actually I saw video for it and
I said that will be the one valve game I
never buy it looks stupid and nerdy and
horrible
it's all-star match 10 slacks vs. team k
she won't do this for reals you want a
piece of it better you use a second
cheonsik are you satisfied thank you so
much sir I'm Helen
remember how you look like a [ __ ]
used-car salesman at the major remember
how I stopped giving a [ __ ] charlie hi
I'm Jake
also known as sir action slacks
regrettably I should have been colonel
quit that was number two so oh god that
would be better well I was 12 a bleep
airplane xbox and halo 1 got some homies
together in my room we got a bunch of
pizzas they all decide we've come up
with our names by the time the night
ended you know 13 hours later after a
few cokes a lot of pizza and that was it
man we was a close one
I got that slack's is it more like
skirts Jesus
I played Team Fortress 2 religiously
once I got a computer
and then a buddy of mine said hey
they're giving away hats in DotA for
diretide now it's like free hats on it
now
dota 2 could be a very aggressive place
for a new player people don't like it
well you don't know what's going on
you're treating [ __ ] you I mean there's
two kinds of people they say I don't
have time for this they move on with
their lives they become successful and
happy and then there's no two people
that say this makes me mad I'm gonna
play it till I in the best in the world
and then they get depressed didn't spend
the rest of their life on it so yeah
that's I'm a dota person like all the
others and I got flamed religiously when
I first started off like most new
players then I decided how can you flame
somebody who sounds like an idiot so I
used to play gyrocopter at like 500
gyrocopter games and I'm horrible at the
hero but the entire time if you're
running around some like an old confused
man nobody flames you they just laugh
about hey everybody how's it gone oh oh
Jesus is a lot of cursing we're
literally way too high listen to you
right now oh my that is open and that's
how I always played my friends were like
you should record yourself in post if
people might like this I was like no
one's gonna like this and they were
mostly right yeah most people didn't but
eventually we got it working you know
I'm kind of the community's creation
unfortunately I was making these dumb
videos and the power cord on my computer
broke or the power supply I looked it up
cost $200 I've been poor my entire life
so I asked the community you guys help
me raise $200 to get this new power cord
so I can keep making these videos go
home to work for nine hours come back
home and on the little 200 dollar
IndieGoGo there was nine thousand
dollars so yeah by the end of it I made
almost 13 grand and I said okay not
gonna waste this I'm gonna get a new
computer I'm going to start streaming
I'm going to fly to ti4
and that ti4 video and that experience
is what got me really interested in
competitive dota and then I decide I
want to do this
my foreseeable future there you go I am
here with my personal hero the man
himself and I I'm sorry House is doing
my friend I was going it's going good
now
I guess da struck why did you ruin my
dreams ah I don't know I was sitting
around it was like you know it will be
really cool ruin someone else's dreams
you would do great things are all enjoy
great interview I said you are a premier
oh yeah we're doing great we're hearing
these very comfortable seats where my
knees are bleeding sitting in what is
this [ __ ] I'm not even huge hello I am
here with a wonderful lady by the name
Oh Oh like a natural disaster oh my god
what's going on over there oh we [ __ ]
made it we made it we're outside of the
dota 2 lounge sweet 24 our dota 2
dissident [ __ ] got us in I told him
our was art easy and they believe so
ends our time at the VIP area the
security that the scooter men got us
high side sighs right here dropping
bombs we're not performing you don't
worry the camera's not on God why you in
line for Denny's honor I miss Vegas wow
it was really eye-opening experience to
be like okay this is what it's all about
this is this world and it's kind of
strange because almost everybody that I
talked to in dota 2 has a long legacy
they've all been there since still 2 1
I mean they've all been working toward
and as a guy that just kind of just got
there and got to see it I feel like it
was a little bit easier for me to
explain it to the masses as well go to
to the - hey I played the original yeah
grandpa tell me more about it
all right are you excited to be on team
slacks aren't easy yeah
now you know what I deal with this is my
life now people take dota extremely
seriously and while there is a place for
that I think there's a lot of room for
to have fun okay
come on [ __ ] you don't even sound
excited what do you got a hand up her
ass oh I'm surprised with that got past
that section that's a big section right
there it's a video game we're gamers we
all enjoy the same thing we have fun
let's have fun together that's kind of
been my mission but you know we'll see
if it works